mario et et julien sont frère et soeur
mais c'est julien l'aîné ils s'aiment si
fort que rien ne peut les séparer
et après qu'est ce qui s'est passé je
sais c'est pas vrai dit s'ils te jure
qu'ils amènent ici
suffit
meilleure façon d'éviter le péché dans
fear les occasions
vous chantez
mais sous dirt
ça passe je serai plus le film
allah
gardez votre nom essayer de contrôler
quelque chose qui vous dépasse
qui nous dépasse tous ce serait une
catastrophe si la chose est connue
nous avons joué c'est toi
les séparer
ils ont mis tout en oeuvre pour nous
séparer mais rien n'y fera
on ne peut pas séparer le sens des
veines la sève de l'arbre il le sel de
la mer